you know i've talked a lot about the
ketogenic diet fasting exercise
how to burn fat
but i haven't really focused on other
things that can help you speed up this
fat burning process
specifically phytonutrient
now what is it about phytonutrients that
can help you lose weight well there's
some pretty serious research on the six
herbs i'm going to talk about in
relationship to turning on certain genes
that have to do with increasing your
metabolism
activating certain genes that can help
you
cause more fat oxidation which is fat
burning and the primary mechanism
of a lot of these herbs has to do with
one thing it helps make insulin more
sensitive insulin is a fat storing
hormone if you have too much insulin
you're not going to lose weight i think
that the best analogy would be someone
that you know that obsessively
communicates to you they just will not
be quiet they keep talking and talking
and talking no matter what you do
um they're a terrible listener and all
they do is talk right after a while
you're going to lose your sensitivity to
their communication you're going to
phase out the same exact thing happens
with your cells
if you have too much communication too
much insulin coming through hormone
communication
your body just becomes insensitive it
just it becomes resistant and it no
longer receives that communication
so what does that cause your body to do
make more communication make more
insulin and that is behind a slow
metabolism that is behind excessive
weight accumulation and also your
inability to lose weight if you take
someone that can lose weight easily uh
no matter what they eat they usually
have
insulin sensitivity they don't have
insulin resistance versus someone else
that
boy they just look at food and they gain
weight they have major insulin
resistance and their body is making more
insulin so anything that improves
insulin resistance will lower insulin
and you're going to get into ketosis fat
burning more and your body is going to
burn more
fat so let's get right into the six
herbs number one in one study which
happened to be in a lab they used human
fat cells by the way
they exposed these fat cells to a
compound in cinnamon called
cinnamaldehyde and they noticed that the
metabolism started speeding up so
cinnamon has certain compounds that
activate your genetics to help you burn
more fat it also is very powerful for a
diabetic since
pretty much all diabetics are insulin
resistant and this is why they recommend
cinnamon to help balance your blood
sugar so it's really
effective for insulin resistance and
making insulin more sensitive and it's
also a very powerful anti-inflammatory
and by the way inflammation in general
makes insulin resistance worse
so cinnamon is a really really great
thing to consume i would get it in a tea
you can take a cinnamon stick and put
that right in your cup and heat it up
and drink that you can put cinnamon in
certain foods you can make these little
keto cookies which have no sugar and add
cinnamon and i want to just say one
thing
just by taking any of these herbs
and not changing your diet you're pretty
much wasting your money it's not going
to work so you have to change your diet
too but they can help you lose a couple
more pounds and make your metabolism a
little bit faster all right number two
turmeric turmeric hands down is probably
one of the most powerful
super herbs that are out there now the
big way that turmeric works is in its
anti-inflammatory properties
the compound in turmeric is curcumin and
because it drops inflammation it
automatically improves insulin
resistance but it also directly
increases fat oxidation and another term
for a fat oxidation is fat burning and
it does it through activating certain
genetics so that's pretty cool all right
number three fenugreek seeds
now typically fenugreek seeds are good
for digestion uh gas bloating
indigestion
but
fenugreek seeds also have a
phytonutrient that directly improves
insulin resistance it makes insulin more
sensitive so therefore lowering insulin
and a lot of people take it for blood
sugars but you can also take it to help
you lose some more weight all right
number four garcinia cambogia this is a
pretty pretty interesting
herb it has very interesting compounds
for a lot of different things
one is cancer but one big effect is
in its ability to help you lose weight
in one study it showed that it can help
you lose up to two pounds more in a two
to twelve week period compared to the
placebo group the main active compound
in this herb is called
hydroxycitrate and hydroxycitrate is
good for many things it's good for
kidney stones it's good to decrease
appetite but it's especially good in
increasing insulin sensitivity it helps
to lower insulin resistance and this is
going to cause you to store less fat and
it was also found there is increased fat
byproducts in the urine after taking
this product for a period of time i'll
put the research down below all right
number five my favorite green tea
its active compound egcg has the ability
to stimulate your metabolism directly it
can also cause fat oxidation directly
especially during exercise in one study
it was demonstrated that it could
increase your fat burning by 17
if combined with exercise so that's
pretty cool i mean green tea is good for
so many things it has anti-cancer
properties anti-inflammatory properties
it helps increase longevity and the list
goes on and on and on all right number
six
berberine berberine in certain studies
shows almost
the exact effect as metformin and
metformin
targets insulin resistance i mean that's
why people take it when they have
diabetes so it makes your cells more
sensitive to insulin it reduces insulin
and also turns off that liver from
producing too much glucose and so you
don't end up with a fatty liver so
berberine is known for blood sugars but
anything that improves blood sugars and
insulin is going to help you lose weight
and so this is why berberine is used for
diabetes it's used for pcos polycystic
ovarian syndrome which is
a female problem with too many androgens
which is caused by too much insulin
too much insulin triggers androgens and
in one study that i read
people that take it over a period of
three months
lose significantly more weight so
berberine is definitely included on this
list so like i said before um if you
take any of these herbs without changing
your diet you're wasting your money but
i wanted to give you some additional
things
to give you um an extra edge in losing
weight and burning fat now if you
haven't seen my other video on how to
accelerate fat burning i put it up right
here i think you'll enjoy it check it
out
you